ça sent la côte d'ivoire avec cette
flambée de violence à l'approché de la
présidentielle du 31 octobre c'est à
abidjan où les affrontements sont les
plus violents des heurts ont éclaté
entre étudiants fasciste proche de
l'opposition une cinquantaine d'inconnus
armés des véhicules ont été incendiés
plusieurs routes barrées dans le pays
l'opposition rejette la candidature
d'alassane ouattara un troisième mandat
à l'appel au boycott du scrutin ainsi
qu'à la désobéissance civile
le porte parole du gouvernement lui
accuse l'opposition d'être derrière ces
violences
ce sont des violences qui sont localisés
dans certaines localités où la plupart
proches de sept leaders d'opinion dao qu
aux noix ou ce qui relève de madame
simone dabo violence il faut le relever
ok ce très manipulés par ces différents
leaders de politiques de l'opposition
soit dit en passant c'est souvent trois
ou quatre localités sous suprême de plus
de 200 communes au niveau national et ce
n'est que si conscrits mais nous suivons
ça avec beaucoup d'attention ou n'est
pas que cela n'aille plus loin que ce
que nous avons observé l'analyste
politique voyant attention vivent depuis
le mois d'août
pour rappel le différend organisations
internationales ont établi le bilan du
mois d'août se disent à 15 mois mais que
la violence a vu en quoi tu vois depuis
une voix doute la goutte d'eau qui a
fait déborder le vase
la liste de l'ue des candidates la
présidentielle
l'essai mené par un d'officiels par le
conseil constitutionnel le 4 septembre
dernier
l'opposition a donc demandé à ses
sympathisants d'utiliser tous les moyens
globaux légaux afin d'empêcher 8 3e -
ba2
sur la scène ouattara est donc
d'empêcher la tenue de la présidentielle
avait cela ne devrait pas empêcher à
proprement parler la tenue de la
présidentielle du 31 octobre prochain
cela ne devrait pas empêcher la série de
le combattre le résultat ou saura-t-il
saisir ma gueule et revenus où qu'ils se
seraient déroulés dans certaines
localités